ก็สวัสดีครับพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูอะตี
สวัสดีค่ะนะครับนักเรียนเย้กลับมาเจอกับ
เรา 2 คนเหรอเออเราสองคนนี่มาเจอกับนัก
เรียนเป็นประจำทุกวันอ้วนจันทร์จันทร์
โอเคล้วนอังคารวันจันทร์วันจันทร์วันนี้
วันจันทร์ครับ
ทุกวันจันทร์โอน
ปฏิทิน
ปฏิทินอีเฮี่ยนสวยๆโอเควันจันทร์ที่เท่า
ไหร่ครับวันนี้วันจันทร์ที่ 1
ว้าววันจันทร์ที่ 1 นะครับเป็นวันต้น
เดือนใช่มั้ยวันจันทร์ต้นเดือนคือวันที่ 1
เดือนอะไรคะวันเกิดเป็นต้นเดือน
สิงหาคมทะเบียนนี้เดือน
สิงหาคมๆเดือนสิงหาคมเดือนที่ 8 ใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ค่ะคนเดือนที่ 8 ปีพศ.อะไรคะปีพตต
2565 ครับ
อะไรคะคศ 2010  22
1024 นายครับแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอน
นี้เป็นเวลาเรียนภาษาไทยครับพูดเล่นล่ะ
ของทุ่ม
08:10 น
ไปหาเรียนภาษาไทย
ที่ประเทศไทยแล้วตอนนี้ที่ประเทศไทย 20:00
นแต่ไม่รู้ว่าที่ประเทศนักเรียนที่นัก
เรียนกำลังดูอยู่เลยกี่โมงไม่รู้ไม่มี
ประเทศไทยตอนนี้ 08:00 นนะคะมาถ้าเป็น
เช็คซาดก็
8:00 นหมอ 5 ถ้าเป็นที่อื่นในอเมริกาเรา
ก็ไม่รู้
ถ้าเป็นอังกฤษยุโรปเวลาก็เปลี่ยนเนาะน่า
จะใช่ครับก็จะต่างกันญี่ปุ่นก็ 22:00 น
อ๋อต่างกันนิดหน่อยนะครับเคค่ะกู Arty
ครับสบายดีไหมคะ 5 สบายดีครับสบายดีบายดี
ตัวเองมีเรื่องจะเล่าให้ฟังแล้วก็มีอะไร
มีอะไรฉันเล่าให้ฟังมีอะไรจะเล่าให้ครัว
ตี้มีอะไรจะเล่าให้นักเรียนฟังเขากว่านี้
จะเอาเออต้องนะต้องสนุกแน่ๆเลยอ่ะต้อง
เป็นเรื่องที่สนุกแน่ๆเลยกูใช่ไหมกูเก็บ
ไว้ไหนแล้วโอเคไปเที่ยวนอนแล้วกรกับมันก็
คอนกล้วยเอา background ออกก่อนแล้วจะได้
เห็นก็
อ๋ออ๋อนี่มีอะไรอยู่ข้างบนกดติ้งให้มา 5
นะคะประมาณมีเพดานแล้วก็มีอะไรอยู่บน
เพดานอันนี้ล่ะคะอันนี้เป็นเครื่องปรับอา
การขอครูเอกจะให้ดูเครื่องปรับอากาศเนื้อ
เพลงเนอะกูดูนักเรียนบอกให้ดูทำไม
คนไทยคนไทยก็เรียกเครื่องปรับอากาศเป็น
ภาษาอังกฤษนะแต่เพียงภาษาอังกฤษแบบสั้นๆ
คนไทยชอบเรียกชื่อย่อชื่อสั้นๆๆเรียกว่า
อะไรคะคนไทยเรียกว่าแอร์ครับแต่เออ
เวลาที่เราพูดคำว่าแออัดอี้อูเอครับเจอ
บ่อยๆนะนักเรียน
วัดเหรอค่ะคนให้แกแกแกรีบเที่ยวเหอะคนคน
ตลาดก็อาจจะคิดว่าเป็นอากาศอากาศอะไรหรอ
คะคนไทยหมายถึงแอร์คอนดิชั่นและแต่แต่เรา
ไม่พูดทับศัพท์อันนี้เลยว่าทับศัพท์นะคะ
หนึ่งแกมาจากอะไรนะคะมาจากแอร์คอนดิชั่น
ห่าทับศัพท์เต็มๆใช่ไหมคะเราพูดสั้นๆคือ
พูดชื่อเล่นแล้วพูดเขาว่าแอร์งั้นน่ะ
เรื่องปออกอากาศคนไทยทั่วไปก็จะไม่ค่อย
พูดนะเครื่องหลบอากาศๆมันยาวคนไทยไม่ชอบ
พูดยาวๆ
เราก็พูดว่าแกโอเคเนาะใช่ครับแปลเป็นคำ
ทับศัพท์นะคะนักเรียนงั้นเอาสั้นๆนะคะ
เครื่องปรับอากาศหรือแอร์เหมือนกันนะคะๆ
ไม่ใช่ออกซิเจนไอ้ไนโตรเจนไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่
อากาศวันไทยไม่ได้ไปถึงอากาศหมายถึง
เครื่องปรับอากาศแต่ว่าแอ
อย่างนี้กู Arty คูเอกขึ้นยังไงข่าวบ้าน
ครูที่บ้านวันนี้วันนี้คุยพูด
ที่บ้านครู Arty ครับเรื่องปรับอากาศ
รู้แล้วก็พูดเครื่องปรับอาจาก
แก
โอเคมีแอร์นะแล้วก็ที่ทำงานก็มีแอร์เนาะๆ
ในที่นี้เนี่ยอะแกก็มีมีหลายแบบนะคะนัก
เรียนก็เป็นที่ออฟฟิศหรือที่ทำงานก็จะ
เป็นแบบที่เป็นตึกสูงๆเขาจะมีปิดเปิด
อย่างเดียวอันนั้นเราไม่เอาเนาะเล่าใน
บ้านนะครับที่นี่ที่น่ากัวเตี้ยมีแอร์
แล้วต้องทำความสะอาดใช่ไหมไส้ครับต้องทำ
ความสะอาด
แล้วบอกว่าล้างแอร์ 5 ไส้ขับล้างแอร์ล้าง
แอร์ไม่เหมือนล้างจานและนักเรียนชนิด
อย่างกินข้าวเสร็จแล้วเราก็ล้านจานล้าง
and  coo อันตี้ล้างเองหรือว่า
โทรศัพท์ตามช่างแอร์มาล้างหน้าควรตี้ล้าง
เองครับ
เปิด in ล้างแอร์เอง
หรอให้ผัว
ก็ไม่ไม่มีความรู้อ๋ออ๋อร้านเองไม่เป็น
ด้วยหลังไม่เป็นนะคะดึงออกก็ไม่เป็นแล้ว
กวนตี้โคโยตี้ล้างเองฉะนั้นก็ Arty ก็อ้ะ
ร้าน 1 ปีกี่ครั้งค่ะอ่า 1 ปีควรตี้ล้าง 2
ครั้งล้างแอร์ 2 ครั้งไปขับกู Arty ก็
ต้องซื้ออุปกรณ์
มีครูตี้มีอุปกรณ์ล้างแอร์ซะหน่อยครับ
บ้านแกกี่ตัวคะเนี่ย
ทีแค่ 3 ตัว
จริงๆแล้วต้องแอร์กี่เครื่องให้ทีเครื่อง
เรียกเครื่องก็ได้เรียกว่า
พี่แอนเนี่ยเขาเรียกเป็นเครื่องนะคะเอา
น้ำเนี่ย 1 ขวด
เป็นเครื่องแต่ว่าช่างแอบหรือบริษัทแอก็
จะพูดมามีตัว
คุณว่าตัวเค้าไม่กี่ตัวนะคะมี 3 ตัวครับ
สามตัวพลังก็ 1 ตัวก็แล้วแต่นกจ่ายบัญชี
ก็ฆ่าร้อยบางทีก็ 800 ครับประมาณประมาณ
800 บาทร้อยได้ครับก็แล้วแต่ราคานะคะที่
นี่ร้ายเองครับคุยล้างไม่เป็น
โทรศัพท์หาครูสวัสดีได้ครับเออให้มาล้าง
แอร์ให้กูเอ๋หน่อยเด้อตัวเท่าไหร่ค่ะ
1 ตัวล่ะครับอะ 1 ตัวราคาพิเศษครับเรา
รู้จักกันเดี๋ยวกลัวติ๊กคิดคู๋อ่าไม่แพง
นะคิดถูกๆคิด 500 พอนิ่มตัว 500 บาทโอเค
โอกาสหน้าพระเอกโทรศัพท์น่ะ
นักราคามาตรฐานขั้นนะครับไปนะคะ 500
เนี่ยเป็นราคามาตรฐานแต่ทีนี้นะครูเอ๋
หน้าไม่ไม่ล้างแอร์เองอ่ะเองเอาไว้ล้าง
ไม่เป็นนะคะแล้วก็ที่บ้านไม่มีอุปกรณ์ขอ
[เพลง]
ปีใหม่ไม่ต้องล้างนะถ้าแกใหม่ยังไม่ต้อง
ล้างอ่าใช้ไปก่อน
ทั้งๆที่ไหนหรอจะสักครู่นะคะเดี๋ยวคุยให้
ดูรูปอื่นอีกอ่ะตัวปกรณ์มีแอร์
เออเราอยากจะล้างแอร์โอเคหายอันนี้มีอะไร
คะเนี่ยอ้าอันนี้ใช่ไหมอันนี้บันไดครับ
บันไดนะคะต้องมีมันใดเลยครับเป็นบันไดที่
ปีนขึ้นไปปีขึ้นไปบนบันไดสูงๆจะได้ล้าง
แอร์ได้เพราะว่าแอร์เนี่ยแกอยู่แกอยู่สูง
ใช่ไหมไอ้อยู่ข้างบนอ้าๆมนสูงต้องใช้
บันไดอาจต้องใช้เวลาอยู่โอเคหาก
เราก็มีบันไดแล้วก็มีอันนี้ค่ะกูอะตีอัน
นี้เป็นค่าใบค่ะเข้าใหม่ลองพื้นรองพื้น
เพราะเวลาล้างแอร์แล้วจะแม่น้ำมีน้ำลงมา
ที่พื้นเพราะไม่อยากให้พื้นเปียกต้องใช้
ผ้าใบปู่ที่พื้น
สมมติว่าโคเอนเอ
มีแอร์อยู่ตรงนี้ครับเหมือนไหมแกอยู่สูงๆ
นะบนผนังสูงๆเลย 5 ตรงนี้ก็อาจจะเป็น
ประตู
ขับก็เป็นพื้นห้องเดอ
[เพลง]
สีดำๆเพราะว่าแอร์สกปรกใช่ไหมความตกน้ำก็
จะดำมากหน่อย
โอเคค่ะมีไม่ลืมอันนึงเกี่ยวกับแอร์ตัว
นี้เขาเรียกว่าอะไรกว่าที่มีอะไรครับฮะ
อันนี้คือเรียกว่าแผ่นกรอง
กรองฝุ่นจะมีฝุ่น
ขอเวลามีพูดเดี๋ยวก็จะไปแล้วมาหาฝุ่นใน
ห้องก็จะไปติดอยู่ที่แผ่นกรองนี้เนอะจะ
ได้ไม่เข้าไปในแอ
ก็ต้องแปะไว้ใช่ครับป้องกันฝุ่นเข้าไปตัว
นี้เนี่ยเห็นเขาบอกว่าต้องล้างทุก 2
อาทิตย์อ่ะใช่ครับสามารถดึงออกมาเองได้
ครับเปิดฝาที่อยู่ด้านหน้าข้างบนแล้วก็
ดึงออกมาเองเอามาล้างได้ง่ายๆได้ครับข้าง
หลังข้างในเนี่ยต้องคนที่ล้างเป็นน้องๆ
ใช่ครับก็โอเคอ่ะแม่จะไปค่ะอุปกรณ์ต่อไป
เออคะอันนี้เป็นถังน้ำใช่ไหมค่ะอันนี้
ข้างน้ำนะคะถังน้ำมันเรียกว่าอะไรอ่ะที่
เขาใส่เข้าไปในแอร์เป็นข้าข้านี้ก็เป็น
ที่จริงเป็นผ้าใบเหมือนกันผ้าใบรองน้ำรอง
น้ำรองน้ำที่เราล้างแอร์ก็จะมีอาจจะเป็น
เอ่อเป็นน้ำยาล้างแอร์ที่มีฟองมีฟองเยอะ
ใช่ไหมเวลาเราล้างน้ำก็จะลงมาในผ้าใบนี้
แล้วก็ลงมาในถังอีกทีนึงเออใช่จะใส่แล้ว
เอาไปทิ้งใต้เอาไปทิ้งได้ง่ายๆนะครับพื้น
ห้องของเราก็จะไม่สกปรกภ่ายก็จะมีน้ำลงมา
แค่นิดหน่อยที่
แล้วตัวนี้ล่ะนี่ไหนอ่ะอันนี้สำคัญเลย
ครับตัวนี้ต้องมีต้องมีตัวนี้ด้วยจะทำให้
ก็ยังไม่ได้เออถ้าไม่มีล้างไม่สะอาด
เออล้างได้ทำไม่สะอาดแต่อันนี้ร้านด้วย
เครื่องมีสะอาดกว่า
เรียกว่าอะไรค่ะกูอาทิตย์อันนี้เป็น
เครื่องฉีดน้ำแต่เป็นเครื่องฉีดน้ำที่แรง
ดันสูง
อาจจะฉีดน้ำได้แรงมากใช้ล่ะ
เค้าฉี่กูเห็นผู้ฉีดเข้าไปในแอร์เลยอ่ะ
อาบหน้าใช่ครับฉีดเข้าไปในแอร์เลยเพราะ
ว่าแรงดันของน้ำที่มีแรงดัน
สูงเนี่ยจะทำให้สิ่งสกปรกฝุ่นที่ติดอยู่
ที่แอร์เนี่ยออกไปได้หลุดออกไปได้หลุด
แล้วก็ลงมาในนี้ๆใช่ครับ
โอเคแล้วก็เขียนมีตัวนี้ด้วยเออตัวนี้ตัว
นี้ก็สำคัญครับตัวนี้ใช้หลังจากที่หลัง
จากที่ฉีดน้ำเสร็จแล้วมันได้เป่าผมเลยนะ
แต่ใช่ๆๆมีแต่ว่าเครื่องนี้ไม่ร้อนเป่า
แล้วไม่ร้อนท่านไดร์เป่าผมเราเป่าผมผมจะ
ร้อนใช่ไหมค่ะนี้ไม่ร้อนมีแต่ลมอย่าง
เดียวเอออะไรค่ะเป่าน้ำที่ติดอยู่ที่แอร์
เวลาเราล้างเสร็จแล้วก็จะมีมีน้ำติดอยู่
ที่แอร์ใช่ไหมค่ะก็เอาเครื่องเป่าลมเนี่ย
เป่าให้น้ำกระเด็นออกไปขอให้ออกไหมเออใช่
ครับไม่ให้ติดอยู่ในแอร์ไม่ต้องค้างอยู่
ในแอร์ไม่ต้องปิดตายใช้ครับอันนี้อ่านี้
กำลังฉีดฉีดล้างเข้าไปในแอร์อยู่นะใช้
เครื่องฉีดน้ำมีแรงดันสูงฉีดเข้าไปเรื่อง
ไม่เสียใช่ไหมคะวันที่ 5 ไม่เสียครับไม่
เสียสามารถเปียกน้ำและถูกน้ำได้เห็นไหม
ครับน้ำที่ครับเขาต้องปิดสวิตช์แอร์ก่อน
ไหมคะได้ใช้ต้องปิดสวิชไอคอนเข้าเปิดไม่
ได้เดี๋ยวไฟดูดไม่ก็กูเอง 2 สูตรเลยเรา
ปิดแอร์แต่ว่าหมายถึงศัพท์คะแต่ว่าต้องลง
ไหมอ่ะอาบปกติแล้วที่แกทั่วไปจะมีคัต
เอาท์สำหรับแออยู่ขอของครูมีไหมห้องเคมี
ที่บ้านครูยังมีแอร์แล้วก็มีคันเอาแอร์
อยู่ข้างๆกัน
กูเองไม่แน่ใจมีคันเอาตัวเล็กๆอยู่ที่
อยู่ที่อยู่ที่ตรงที่ติดเกาะรีโมทนะครับ
ที่แขวนรีโมทอยู่ตรงไหน
นี่ที่แขวนมีอยู่ที่นี่แหละที่อยู่อยู่บน
โต๊ะเหรอไม่มีคัตเอาท์อยู่จะมีเขาแอร์
อยู่กูเอกก็ถามช่างนะว่าจะจะให้ปิดสับ
สวิตช์คันเอาไว้ฮะสับสวิตช์มั้ยช่างมัน
ไม่เป็นไรครับเดี๋ยวผมจัดการเองอ๋อโอเค
สวิตซ์ได้ครับเค้าน่าจะรู้ว่าตรงไหนอ่ะ
เออมันมีอยู่ครับมันมีอยู่
ตอนนี้นักเรียนก็รู้จักแล้วนะคะว่าอันนี้
คือเวลาที่จะล้างแอร์ก็ต้องมีมีอะไรนะมี
มีถุง
มีผ้าใบรองน้ำแฮนะครับหารองน้ำที่ล้าง
แอร์นี่อาจมีตัวนี้หน้าเครื่องเป่าลมโอเค
ถามหรือบัญชีเขาก็ได้พักเรียบทับศัพท์เลย
เนาะใช่ครับในน้ำโบเวอร์ถ่ายเลข Rover
แล้วก็ตัวนี้ก็เป็นเอ่อเครื่องฉีดน้ำแรง
ดันสูงนะค่ะอันนี้ก็เป็นครั้งน้ำชายถัง
น้ำ
แล้วก็มีอะพญางูพื้นใช่ครับ
มันใดอ่ะปาร์ตี้มีครบเลยล่ะค่ะอ้ามีครบ
เลยครับอ๋อสามารถล้างแอร์ในหมู่บ้านได้
ทุกบ้านไม่ล้างครับล้างบ้านตัวเองก็พอ
แล้วครับ
ถ้ามีเพื่อนบ้านบอกอาตี้ช่วยหน่อยก็ร้าน
ให้หน่อยโอเคคะเดี๋ยวกลัวตีโทรเรียกจะ
ช่างล้างแอร์ให้เขาดีกว่าเนาะ
นายให้หนังเรื่องนี้อาจ
ไม่เป็น
โทรศัพท์เบอร์โทรไปหาช่างแอร์ดีกว่า
เดี๋ยวกลัวตี้เป็นช่างแอร์ให้มาเดี๋ยววัน
นี้นะคะนักเรียนเสื้อนักเรียนอยู่ประเทศ
ไทยแล้วก็แอร์มีปัญหาอย่างแอของครูเอ๋ค่ะ
หาเคค่ะหนึ่งต้องล้างรัฐประมาณ 6 เดือน
แล้วก็ 2 มีน้ำขอมีน้ำหยดออกมาให้มีน้ำ
หยดตอนนี้หน้าฝนฝนตกข้างนอกแต่ฝนตกในห้อง
คุย
วันที่กูเอกก็ต้องปิดแอร์ทำงานแล้วก็ร้อน
มากโอ้โห
เขาก็เปิดแล้วมันก็จะมีน้ำกระเด็นลงมานะ
คะโทรโทรไปหาช่างแอร์กลับพ่อเขาที่แล้ว
คุณครูเอ๋มีช่างมาทำแต่ไม่ใช่บริษัทของ
แอร์ขับเอกก็ได้ตัดสินใจนะคะกู Arty อ่ะ
ไม่รู้ไม่รู้จะหาช่างแอร์ที่ไหนครับดีๆ
เออถ้าไม่รู้นะคะนักเรียนนั่งเดียวดูนี่
ที่ขี้แอร์เลยค่ะเค้าจะมีสติ๊กเกอร์แปะ
เอาไว้นะคะๆบอกว่าเป็นแอร์ยี่ห้ออะไรนะๆ
ถามเขาจะมีสติ๊กเกอร์แปะเอาไว้ว่าอ้ะ
เบอร์โทรศัพท์ที่เราจะโทรไปแล้วก็ติดต่อ
นะฮะหน้าเพื่อให้อะพนักงานหรือช่างเข้ามา
ดูแอร์น่ะหรือเบอร์อะไรกูอีกโทรศัพท์มือ
เบอร์โทรศัพท์ติดอยู่ที่เครื่องแอร์ได้
ครับให้ติดอยู่ในเครื่องแอร์ก่อนโทรเลย
ค่ะ
โทรโทรโทรไปใช่ไหมคะอ่ะครับสวัสดีค่ะและ
บริษัทดาต้ายหาโอเคอ่ะโทรมาแล้วใช่ไหม
เดี๋ยวขวดดีขึ้นล็อคหายก่อนเป็นอัตโนมัติ
ก่อน
ติดต่อ
ซื้อสินค้ากด 1
ฝ่ายบริการหลังการขายกดสองเออมันจะบอกติด
ต่อฝ่ายบริการหลังการขายไทยขับคือเขาขาย
มาแล้ว
จะติดต่อใครก็บริการหลังการขายแล้วกันเออ
สายโทรไปได้ซื้อมาแล้วก็โทรไปได้เหมือน
กันนะโทรไปแต่
สุดท้ายครับหน้าบริษัทแออายี่ห้ออะไรครับ
Samsung เนี้ยอ้ะมันแอร์ซัมซุงครับยินดี
รับใช้ครับสวัสดีค่ะน้องแอร์พี่มีฝนตกอ๋อ
We  Have ฝนตก 5 ตอนนี้แอร์อยู่ในบ้าน
หรืออยู่นอกบ้านครับอยู่ในในบ้านแอร์น้ำ
หยดขออ๋อมีน้ำหยดออกมาจากแอร์โอเคไหมครับ
ฮ่ามีน้ำหยดออกมาจากแอร์
น้ำหยดมากี่วันแล้วครับประมาณ 3 วันแล้ว
ค่ะน้องหยดทุกวันที่เปิดเลยใช่ไหมครับๆจะ
เป็นตอนหน้าฝนอ่ะโอเคแอร์เครื่องนี้แก
เครื่องนี้ใช้มานานหรือยังครับ
น่าจะเจ็บปีแล้วก็อ้อน 7 ปีแล้วโอเคโอเค
ครับเอ่อคุณลูกค้าทราบชื่อรุ่นของแอร์ไหม
ครับรุ่นหรอคะใช้อ่าไม่ทราบค่ะดูตรงไหน
เดี๋ยวดูให้นะคะได้ครับได้ครับจะมี
สติ๊กเกอร์แปะอยู่ข้างแอร์ครับสติ๊กเกอร์
หรอคะในครับขอดูสติกเกอร์อีกหนึ่งได้ครับ
เห็นแล้วค่ะสติ๊กเกอร์
สติ๊กเกอร์โอเค
สติ๊กเกอร์เขียนว่าเป็นแอร์รุ่นอะไรครับ
ช่า
as10  UD  pn ค่ะอ๋อโอเค s10 ยูจีพีเอ็น
โอเคเดี๋ยวผมขอเช็คอ่า
อายุการรับประกันของแอร์เครื่องนี้หน่อย
ครับ
คุณลูกค้าหา Serial  Number ให้ผมหน่อย
ตัวไหนคะค่ะมีสีก็ Number อยู่ที่เห็นแต่
แรงดันไฟฟ้ากระแสไฟฟ้ากำลังไฟฟ้า
ประสิทธิภาพพลังงานมอเตอร์
Serial ไม่เห็นค่ะมีเซอร์สติ๊กเกอร์อยู่
ที่อื่นอีกไหมครับที่ขึ้นต้นด้วย s  n
เลยครับมีไหมครับอ่ะๆน้าๆ
พี่ขึ้นต้นด้วย s  n มีไหมมีไหมขอดูก่อน
นะคะๆครับ
โอเคเจอแล้วค่ะโอ้เจอแล้วตอนนี้ครับ S
แล้วก็มีขีดแล้วก็ n ใช่ไหมคะครับเออโอเค
แล้วมีใหม่เลขอะไรต่อครับก็มีมีคิว 07  EP
ดี
cb900  350w ค่ะโอเคครับ 900  350w  5
เครื่องนี้นะเครื่องนี้ยังคงอยู่ในประกัน
นะครับคุณลูกค้าสามารถแจ้งซ่อมได้ครับ
สามารถซ่อมได้เรายังมีอะไหล่อยู่ครับยัง
ขายรุ่นนี้อยู่ใน
ท้องตลาดครับผมทำอันนี้มันมีน้ำรั่วค่ะ
โอเคมีน้ำรั่วนี้ต้องให้ช่างมาดูหรือว่า
ต้องล้างนะคะเอ่อเดี๋ยวเอาผมจะส่งทีมช่าง
เข้าไปดูครับต้องส่งทีมช่างเข้าไปดูก่อน
ว่าสาเหตุของน้ำรั่วเนี่ยเกิดมาจากอะไร
บ้างนะครับนั่งแล้วช่างจะเข้ามาวันไหนคะ
คุณลูกค้าสะดวกวันไหนบ้างครับอีกซักผ้า
พรุ่งนี้หรือมะรืนนี้ดีครับวันอังคารค่ะ
วันอังคารขอวันอังคารนะวันอังคารก็พรุ่ง
นี้ใช่ไหมครับแล้ววันนี้วันจันทร์
บ่าย 2 โมงได้ค่ะบ่าย 2 โมงนะครับหน้า OK
ได้ครับเดี๋ยวประมาณบ่าย 14:00 นผมให้
ช่างโทรเข้าไปติดต่อก่อนนะครับเพื่อที่จะ
เข้าไปดูแลนะครับอาขอเบอร์ติดต่อพี่เบอร์
นี้เลยนะคะได้ครับเบอร์ 084  074  452
โอเค
อาอาน้องต่อพี่ที่อยู่เอาไหมคะอ่าอ่ะที่
อยู่เอาสิอา
ชูซอยอะไรครับเห็ดไหนครับสุขุมวิท 62 ค่ะ
สุขุมวิท 62 ครับผมถนนนะคะถนนสุขุมวิท 62
ครับเอามาเป็นคอนโดนะคะคอนโดชื่ออะไรครับ
มันโดนชื่อชื่ออะชื่อเล็กค่ะเออ next
Condo โอเคอยู่ในฟังดูน่าเดี๋ยวผมไปถึง
คอนโดแล้วผมจะโทรหาคุณลูกค้าอีกทีนึงนะ
ครับได้ค่ะนอน 2:00 นนะครับมาจากปากซอย
เข้ามาตอนน่าจะประมาณซักอ่ะ 200 เมตรนะคะ
โอเคได้ครับ next  Condo  Sukhumvit  62
นะครับโอเคเดี๋ยวเจอกันพรุ่งนี้ครับ
เดี๋ยวช่างจะโทรหาพี่ใช่ไหมคะใช่ครับ
เดี๋ยวพรุ่งนี้ก่อน 14:00 นผมจะโทรไปก่อน
ครับแล้วราคาค่ะราคาอ่ะเดี๋ยวเดี๋ยว
เดี๋ยวให้เจ้าหน้าที่เข้าไปดูก่อนว่าเสีย
จากอ่าตรงส่วนไหนเราถึงจะตอบได้ครับว่า
ราคาเท่าไหร่ค่ะนะครับครับผมขอบคุณมาก
ครับผมสวัสดีครับ
เออโอเค
นะไม่เปลี่ยนก็แบบนี้ถ้าเราโทรศัพท์ไป
เนาะช่างเขาก็จะบอกนะคะๆไม่ใช่ช่องเจ้า
หน้าที่ที่รับโทรศัพท์นะคะเขาก็ได้ช่าง
ติดต่อกลับมาเราก็แจ้งราคาทีหลังหลังจาก
ที่รู้แล้วนะครับหลังจากที่รู้แล้วอะไร
เสียนะครับต้องเปลี่ยนอุปกรณ์ในแอร์หรือ
เปล่าก็จะบอกไปหาเท่าไหร่ต้องเปลี่ยนอะไร
บ้างใช่ครับก็จะมี 2 อย่างครับก็อตตี้คือ
เขาก็จะแบบให้มาล้างแอร์ก่อนนะคะถ้าล้าง
แล้วอุปกรณ์ไม่มีปัญหาไม่ต้องจ่ายเงินถ้า
เจอคือไม่ต้องไม่ต้องไม่ต้องซื้ออะไหล่
ใหม่ๆครับแต่ว่าถ้าถ้าอ่าถ้าเกิดว่าอร่อย
เสียเขาก็จะเอาอะไหล่มาครับน่าเจอ 2  2
อย่างถ.ครั้งที่แล้วเนี่ยคืนกดไม่ได้
อ่านบทหรือเปล่าครับพระเอกไม่ใช่ทานเนี่ย
ช่างมาแล้วทานหมดที่โดนช่างดูนะเลยทำไม
ไม่ดูถ่านคือตัวรับสัญญาณอ๋ออ๋อตัวรับ
สัญญาณที่แอร์เนี่ยรีโมทแล้วกดไปแล้วอ่ะ
รีโมทตังค์แล้วแต่แอร์ไม่ทำเลยให้คือกู M
เปลี่ยนถ่านแล้วแต่ว่าตัวรับสัญญาณน่ะ
เสียไม่รู้ว่าเกิดจากช่างแอบคนก่อนอ๋อที่
มาล้างแอร์แล้วทำเสียเหรอคือเสียง 2
ครั้งแล้วนะแรกเนี่ยมีค่าแก่คนหนึ่งบอกก็
เดี๋ยวซื้อมา
1500 โป๊
ถามโทรไปที่บริษัทบริษัทบอกบ้านเดี๋ยวมา
ดูให้ก็คือต้องล้างก่อนเนาะฆ่าล้างประมาณ
800 กว่าๆต่อเข้า LINE แอบประมาณ 800
กว่าบาทแล้วก็มาดูดูเครื่องให้เขาก็เขา
บอกว่าตรงเนี้ยไม่ต้องซื้อทั้งเซตช่างก็
จะเอาอะไหล่มาก่อนข้าไหลมาแล้วก็มาแล้วก็
ขอดูอ่ะตัวนี้เสียตัวนี้ไม่เสียหรืออะไร
สิบจ่ายแคบ 800 บาทเนี่ยอ๋อ
มัน 5 เครื่องเก่าเนี่ย 2,500 บาทครับ
พรุ่งนี้แปดร้อยต่ออ๋ออ๋อเขียนได้ล้าง
แอร์ด้วยโอโห้ดีเลยแบต 500 แอบต่างหาก
หนังเห้ยก็รู้แล้วนะคะติดต่อคุยกับ
บริษัทตั้งแอร์บริษัทแออย่างไรนะครับโอเค
หมอมโนวันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วถ้ายังมีเวลาอีก
นิดหน่อยสองนาทีนะครับ
ใช่ครับก็หมดเวลา
เวลาที่พนักงานมาแล้วเขาก็จะโทรศัพท์ขานะ
ครับได้เขาก็จะบอกสวัสดีครับผมเป็นช่าง
แอร์จากบริษัท
Samsung  R กับตอนนี้อยู่ตอนนี้อยู่ข้าง
ล่างครับๆหายที่เขาก็อยู่ที่นิติบอกตอน
นี้ผมอยู่ที่นิติครับก็คือออฟฟิศที่ดูแล
คอนโดชายเขาจะไม่ให้เขาจะไม่ให้คนอื่นที่
ไม่ใช่เจ้าของห้องขึ้นไปอ่าเจ้าของห้องก็
ต้องลงมาแล้วก็รับเขาขึ้นไปนะครับหรือ
ครับช่างมานะคะแล้วเวลาช่างเข้ามาในห้อง
แล้วนักเรียนก็ต้องบอกเขาว่าก๊อกน้ำเออ
เออก๊อกน้ำกอล์ฟไหนที่จะให้เขาใช้ได้ใช่
สายครับก็ช่างเขาก็จะไปก็อปที่ในห้องน้ำ
ตัวเองบอกไม่ต้องไม่ต้องไปที่ระเบียบขอ
อ้าที่ระเบียงก็มีก๊อกน้ำเหนื่อยระเบียง
ข้างนอกดิก๊อกน้ำใส่ข้างนอกดีกว่า
เราเขาก็จะถามนักเรียนแบบนี้นะคะแล้วนัก
เรียนมีคำถามอะไรเกี่ยวกับการล้างแอร์ติด
ต่อบริษัทยังไงก็เอาไม่ได้เนาะนายครับ
ล็อกไปหากูอ่ะชอบของบริษัทแอร์เลยอ๋ออ๋อ
เพราะว่าเขารู้แน่นอนเขารู้จักแอของเขา
แน่นอนสายครับท้อช่างที่เป็นเป็นที่อื่น
นะคะทำเสียง
ก็จะคิดโอเคก็จะมีช่างที่เอ่อล้างแอร์ทุก
ยี่ห้อซ่อมแอร์ทุกยี่ห้อด้วยเหมือนกันนะ
เวลาโทรไปนะครับแต่ถ้าเบอร์โทรที่เบอร์
ที่ติดอยู่ข้างแอร์จะได้ช่างของบริษัทแอ
บริษัทนั้นเลยทรายหรือเขาก็จะมีบริษัท
บริษัททรัพย์บริษัททรัพย์ก็เกย์บริษัทที่
เป็นเป็นล้างแอร์ทุกยี่ห้อจะต้องเข้าไป
บริษัทนี้เพื่อเรียน
ของบริษัทนี้นะคะภายเขาก็จะรู้ว่าอันนี้
มันล้างง่ายล้างยากหลังเขาก็จะรู้ว่าตรง
ไหนที่เป็นจุดที่ต้องระวังอ่ะตรงไหนที่
ต้องดูแลเป็นพิเศษจ่ายครับ
โอเคโอเคหลังเอกกันเป็นแค่เย็นสมัยแล้ว
ค่ะเออจ่ายไป 800 แนวเย็นสบายเลยครับ
นักเรียนเรียกช่างข้างนอกก็จะ 500 ต่อ
เครื่อง
แต่ว่าอาจจะเสียมั้ยอ่ะอ่าโอเคโอเคได้
ครับดู Arty กับผู้เอกก็ต้องไปก่อนนะเฮ้อ
หมดเวลาครับเดี๋ยวเขาน่ารักกลับมาเจอกัน
ใหม่ครับในช่องคอม friend จะโลไทยวันนี้
เราสองคนลาไปก่อนนะครับสวัสดีครับครูเอ๋
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนบ๊ายบาย